- [Instructor] The table below shows
solar panel installations by state
during the last fiscal year.
How many total solar panels
were installed last year in Wyoming?
So we look at the state, so
this right over here is Wyoming
and this whole table is
about solar installations
by states during the last year,
so this is the Wyoming
during the last year.
This is the first quarter,
so the first three months,
the second three months,
the third quarter,
the fourth quarter and
this right over here
is the total number of solar panels
that were installed in Wyoming last year,
which is what I think
they're asking us for,
so let's just type that in, 104.
We got it right.
Let's do another one.
The table below indicates
the points scored
by four players in a
charity basketball game.
How many points did Ben have in total?
So here is Ben right over here.
It's broken down by quarter,
but we care about his total
number of points, which is 31.
So Ben had a total of 31 points.
So this indicates the points
scored by four players
in a charity basketball game again.
How many points did Vanessa
score in the fourth quarter?
So let's look at, this is Vanessa,
and we care about the fourth quarter,
so she scored four points
in the fourth quarter.
Put four right over there.
Alright.
So once again, we're talking
about solar panel installations
by state during the last fiscal year.
How many solar panels were installed
in Alabama in the second quarter, in Q2?
So Alabama in the second quarter,
so that's this right over here,
28 solar panels were installed.
So 28.
So this is once again in a charity game.
How many points did Kevin
score in the third quarter?
So Kevin in the third quarter,
he scored nine, nine points.
And one more just for fun.
So how many points did Gabriela
score in the third quarter.
Well, same idea, Gabriela, third quarter,
she scored five points.